if people out there think that the
moment you start achieving some success
that things are going to get easier it
gets worse there are more opportunities
and therefore your structure gets
disrupted more email more texts come in
more amazing possible relationships and
places to eat and things to do it
actually starts to undermine the whole
process if you're not careful I have a
list and now I make it every day because
when I just put it next to me it
literally starts dog walk number one get
sun I mean like really basic stuff then
I do a 90 minute work block which means
I use the program freedom on the
computer no internet no phone I turn off
the phone I put in my car sometimes it's
really bad I mean the phone is such a
pull ask me for some code to get into
something and then I think I need the
phone next thing I'm doing something
else but what's beautiful is that the
nervous system has this feature to it
where when we take chaos of choice and
we restrict ourselves to one of those
choices you get a neurochemical payoff
and it comes in the form of dopamine
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle but you know you're
capable of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Andrew huberman and my take on his top
10 was a success enjoy
there's something about activities that
are forced restriction to one particular
Focus right so I'm gonna write for 90
minutes or I'm going to
um think for 90 minutes or I'm just
gonna walk the dog I live in an area now
where I don't get reception on my dog
walks at first it was excruciating I
love it now it's like I just walked the
dog and there's morning sorry I have a
bulldog he does not like to walk so I'm
like I gotta get back and I'm frustrated
and I know and it's hilarious right
because I notice myself
and the way that my my
um tripwire to agitation is so slight
I'm like one of these people I can just
in a second I'm aggravated because it's
not happening as quickly and so I've
learned to make the whole walk a process
of me just like
recognizing these features of myself and
my Bulldog Costello just plodds a lot he
could care less right so the walk is
very it's only about walking the dog and
the the email if it's email is only
about checking email right and there's
something valuable to this and I think
the brain loves this when we give it
this and the Brain
unfortunately is also happy to just take
a smorgasbord of you know pseudo-random
thoughts and actions all day every day
but there's something so deeply
satisfying about focus and
um
I think we could all uh benefit from
doing more of that it's just so hard to
do and I'm not an anti-phone guy I'm
from Silicon Valley I use the phone I'm
addicted to my phone I admit it I'm
addicted to my phone but I'm trying
really hard to cultivate a different
relationship to it because I think that
uh in now that it's 2021 I think looking
back phones we've had them for about 10
years there are so many examples of ways
in which they erode our best
relationship to life so many ways
that I don't think we should get rid of
them but I think we really need to start
being conscious of of the ways in which
they are eroding our productivity our
creativity our relationships and I don't
have any obvious answers to this I just
have tools that I use
um and that I've found to be a benefit
but I think in the next five years we
are going to see a shift toward people
really moving away from from phones in
um as much as we use them now rule
number two use stress to grow I have
really tried to adopt this idea that
when it's inevitable and it will
inevitably arrive that stress grows us
that it really sharpens decision making
it really sharpens decision making and
you know if you have a very stressful
event and then you recover from it that
the worst thing to do is just go and
keep going you need to take some time
and reflect about what led into that so
I think I'm very good at leveraging fear
into positive change if I really think
about most of the major shifts in my
life it was
I'm scared as hell to remain in this
situation and I'm very good at
broadcasting fear into my future uh you
know if I've ever been in a bad
relationship it was clearly if I stayed
in it could have been so bad that I felt
like I had to leave so I would broadcast
and project you know how horrible it
would be for my future children and I
might even build that up a little bit my
system now one could say well maybe you
could have navigated it successfully I'm
better at projecting fear into my future
and that has led me to make I think
better and better decisions over time
rule number three never say maybe
dopamine as I've said is involved in
anticipation of wanting not of having
it's involved in motivation toward the
thing that you want and it biases us
towards action
reward prediction error equals the
actual amount of dopamine that's
released in response to something versus
minus the amount that's expected okay so
if you tell a kid we might have ice
cream they hear we're going to have ice
cream and they expect it and if you
later say well we're not going to have
ice cream and I said maybe that's
actually going to lead to a much bigger
crash in dopamine it's going to lead to
a negative signal a punishment signal
it's gonna literally going to feel like
pain so kids you can leverage this
if your parents say maybe they're
effectively telling your dopamine system
absolutely now adults are like this too
if we think something might happen and
it doesn't happen there's a big crash in
our in our affect and our emotionality
and that's because that dopamine system
goes from firing about three to four
times per second to about 10 or 15 times
per second in the possibility that
something might happen possibility is
deeply woven into our biology of the
dopamine and motivation system as a way
for us presumably in ancient times to
explore novel territories and get a
sense that maybe there's water there
maybe there are mates there maybe
there's better food there maybe there's
resources there the maybe is an
important thing that in language terms
maybe means maybe but in neurobiological
terms maybe means perhaps there's going
to be the surprise of an even bigger
dopamine reward and the one thing
dopamine loves more than anything else
is surprise rule number four reduce
social media use social media getting
dopamine hit after dopamine hit
when we first get on social media after
a while for the first time or after a
long period of time the amount of
dopamine that's released we think is
quite substantial it's novel remember
dopamine is about novelty surprise and
the sense that we are on some exciting
track that's what dopamine is really
about it puts us into states of
Readiness anticipation looking seeking
Etc almost always for things outside the
confines of our skin just to contrast it
maybe for a bit more of a future
discussion
serotonin does the opposite when there's
a lot of serotonin in our brain and body
typically it makes us feel satisfied
sated and more quiet and comfortable
with what we have in our own immediate
sphere and within us right the comfort
of a good meal the food you have
dopamine is about go go if you look at
somebody who's high on cocaine or
Methamphetamine it's all about Pursuit
because that's a very dopaminergic drug
you look at somebody who's taking a drug
and I'm not suggesting people do this
but it really ramps up serotonin let's
say a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor Prozac Zoloft Etc the side
effects of those drugs if the dosages
are too high lack of appetite lack of
libido kind of meh about life you know
then so they'll adjust the dose down
that's because those are serotonergic
drugs so in in general
when we are in pursuit of things
dopamine is is quite high so now you
have to remind me your question because
I've set up the dopamine serotonin uh
cell phones uh cell phones yes
um forgive me so
the thing about cell phones is when you
first get on there and you haven't let's
say you're no Wi-Fi on the flight or
something and you land it can actually
be quite stimulating you get a lot of
dopamine oh there's this oh there's that
but very quickly when you're scrolling
on social media
you're no longer getting the novelty but
you're continuing to do it you almost
don't know why you're doing it at that
point it shifts over to something that's
a bit more like an obsessive compulsive
Behavior where that we can define an
obsessive-compulsive Behavior where the
obsession leads to a compulsion so the
obsession is a thought that compulsion
is a behavior but the acting out of the
compulsion merely serves to increase the
obsession right this is very different
than being obsessed with food or
obsessed with cleanliness there's no
payoff right exactly there's no Anxiety
Relief by carrying out the compulsion
with OCD behaviors
like scrolling social media the dopamine
quickly wanes and then you find that
you're just sort of and we've all been
there you're scrolling you're like why
am I doing this this isn't that
interesting that is this isn't that
interesting now the algorithms for
social media are very clever and I don't
want to demonize it I you know provide a
lot of a lot of my life has spent on you
know on social media now but
in the algorithms that they've
Incorporated function on the the most
powerful way to keep people doing a
behavior or an animal for that matter is
intermittent random reward a random
intermittent reward that you don't know
when you're going to hit the jackpot so
you're scrolling you're scrolling and
then you see something typically it's
very high what you know in nerd speak
we'd say signal to noise so if you're
reading some interesting things this
came out in the news this came out and
then it's all of a sudden a riot or a
person that is Jump is base jumping off
a building or
um you know for people that are are
scrolling looking at bodies or something
like that uh live bodies and hopefully
people aren't looking at the dead bodies
but look if something's very tragic then
that has this gravitational pull and
then you what happens is you start
getting
the system working for that next
dopamine hit that you don't know when
it's going to come it's just like
gambling so I look at social media as
initially being very dopaminergic
driving rewards surprise and excitement
but very quickly transitioning to
something more like OCD and the kinds of
behaviors where it looks if you if we
were to look at ourselves through the
lens of an experiment like we would an
animal experiment we think that animal
is sick if you saw an animal digging in
the corner looking looking looking
looking for a bone the dog is looking
looking looking looking looking you'd
think that's really sad that's us right
that's us I'm pointing myself
intentionally that's us so we have to
learn to self-regulate the amount of
time but that doesn't have to be a
process of you know scruffing ourselves
and saying don't do it don't do it think
about it in terms of the positive the
more time away from something the more
positively reinforcing it will be when
you return also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five become more focused
there are behavioral tools that you can
use to enhance Focus things like staring
in a particular visual Target at the
same distance at which you're going to
perform some work and doing that for 30
to 60 seconds
narrowing in a very deliberate way your
visual field and then moving into a
focused work bout
that behavioral practice of narrowing
your visual aperture
will increase the amount of
acetylcholine Transmission in particular
neural circuits that will then make it
easier to focus how do we know that well
I covered in that episode some of the
peer-reviewed studies that relate to
protocols that are now actively being
deployed in schools in China and
elsewhere where kids are doing
deliberate visual Focus exercises in
order to increase their mental focus and
while they're not doing micro dialysis
or brain Imaging on those kids in real
time the cognitive effects and indeed
the performance effects in terms of
academic ability and output are pretty
impressive so acetylcholine increases
Focus we talked about some dietary and
some supplementation based ways to
improve acetylcholine or I should say
increase acetylcholine and that does in
fact lead to increases in one's ability
to focus this is why a lot of the
prescription drugs for the treatment of
Alzheimer's age-related cognitive
decline and indeed even some of the
drugs that tap into treatments for ADHD
also involve the acetylcholine system so
there's nothing surprising or heretical
here but it is important to point out
that your behavioral ability to focus is
also related to your ability to access
and deploy acetylcholine so never do we
want
purely pharmacologic treatments to be
the only way that people are increasing
a given neuromodulator I always say
behaviors first then nutrition then
supplementation and then if there's a
need certainly a clinical need then
prescription drugs Etc of course
administered through a physician rule
number six leverage Pleasure and Pain
and nowadays there's a ton of interest
in social media and in video games and
it there have been some measurements of
the amount of dopamine released video
games especially video games that have a
very high update speed where there's
novel territory all the time novelty is
a big stimulus of dopamine those can
release dopamine somewhere between
nicotine and cocaine so very high levels
of dopamine release
social media is an interesting one
because the amount of dopamine that's
released in response to logging onto
social media initially could be quite
high but it seems like likely that
there's a taper in the amount of
dopamine but and yet people still get
addicted so why why is it that we can
get addicted to things that fail to get
to elicit the same massive amount of
pleasure that they initially did
being addicted to something isn't just
about the fact that it feels so good
that you want to do it over and over
again and that's because of this
pleasure pain balance that underlies
motivation so let's look a little bit
closer at the pleasure pain balance
because therein lies the tools for you
to be able to control motivation toward
healthy things and avoid motivated
behaviors towards things that are
destructive for you there are a lot of
reasons why people try novel behaviors
whether or not those are drugs or
whether or not those are Adventure
thrill seeking things or they seek out
new partners or you know they take a new
class as you'll notice I'm not placing
any judgment or value on these different
behaviors although I think it's fair to
point out that for most people
addictive drugs like cocaine and
amphetamine are very destructive
actually we know that about 15 to 20
percent of people have a genetic bias
towards addiction that you know you
sometimes hear that the first time that
you use a drug you can become addicted
to it that's actually not been shown to
be true for most things in most people
but for some people that actually is
true and we'll talk a little bit later
about why certain people are heavily
biased toward becoming addicts on the
first use of a particular drug it's
actually very interesting it has
everything to do with whether or not
they were formally addicted to something
else
but in any case the way that addiction
works and the way that motivation Works
generally in the non-addictive setting
is that when you anticipate something a
little bit of dopamine is released and
then when you reach that thing you
engage in that thing
the amount of dopamine goes up even
further but as you repeatedly pursue a
behavior and you repeatedly engage with
a particular thing let's say you love
running or you love chocolate as you eat
a piece of chocolate believe it or not
it tastes good and then there's a shift
away from activation of dopamine and
there are other chemicals that are
released that trigger a low level sense
of pain now you might not feel as
physical pain but the craving that you
feel is both one part dopamine and one
part the mirror image of dopamine which
is the pain or the craving for yet
another piece of chocolate and this is a
very important and subtle feature of the
dopamine system that's not often
discussed people always talk about just
as pleasure you love social media so it
gives you dopamine and so you engage in
that you like chocolate it releases
dopamines you do that but for every bit
of dopamine that's released there's
another circuit in the brain that
creates you can think of it as kind of
like a downward deflection in pleasure
so you engage in something you really
want and there's an increase in pleasure
and then there's a without you doing
anything there's a mirror image of that
which is a downward deflection and
pleasure which we're calling pain so for
every bit of pleasure there is a mirror
image experience of pain and they
overlap in time very closely so it's
sometimes hard to sense this but try it
the next time you eat something really
delicious you'll take a bite it tastes
delicious and part of the experience is
to want more of that thing this is true
for any pleasureful experience
now the Diabolical part about dopamine
is that because it didn't evolve in
order to get you to indulge in more and
more and more of something what happens
is that initially you experience an an
increase in pleasure and you also
experience this increase in pain shortly
after or woven in with the pleasure
that makes you want more of that thing
but with each subsequent time that you
encounter that thing that you pursue the
chocolate that you uh you pursue the
lover each time the experience of
dopamine release and pleasure is
diminished a little bit
and the Diabolical thing is that the
pain response is increased a little bit
and this is best observed in the context
of drug-seeking behavior the first time
someone decides to take cocaine or
amphetamine
they may do it out of boredom they may
do it out of peer pressure they may do
it to relieve some internal sense maybe
they're bored or they're just excited
maybe they're high in novel novelty
seeking there are a lot of reasons why
people might try a drug far too many for
us to you know to get into or parse here
maybe they don't even want to do it but
someone encourages them they will
experience a huge dopamine release and
they will feel likely very good
however the next time they take it it
won't feel quite as good and it won't
feel even as good the third time or the
next time but
the amount of pain the amount of craving
that they experience for the drug will
increase over time so much of our
pursuit of pleasure is simply to reduce
the pain of craving so the next time you
experience something you really like I
don't want to take you out of that
experience but it's really important
that you notice this that if there's
something you really enjoy part of that
enjoyment is about the anticipation and
wanting of more of that thing
and that's the pain system in action
rule number seven take a break learning
to cultivate a a life of focus and I
should say it should be produ the way to
support that is to have components of
your day of wordlessness and defocus I
do want to emphasize that because it's
not about waking up and from morning
till till night being Ultra focused
right I don't I don't I don't do the
make my bed first thing I admit it I I
sometimes like it happens midday okay
all right I wouldn't make it in the
military but we knew that already anyway
so the you know that it's about being
in in recognition of where you're at and
focused and dropping in deeply for
certain portions of the day but I also
have a deliberate decompress time of my
day right I take 30 minutes a day and I
either take a nap or I do a Yoga Nidra
or I just let my mind go but that does
mean not mindless scrolling although I
do some mindless scrolling too I allow
myself that but
having periods of the day where you let
the mind defocus and just kind of drift
in the same way that your mind drifts a
bit during sleep that is what allows you
to focus so it very intensely afterward
or on a consistent basis so it's not
about being a total animal from morning
till night and then just expecting a
switch you know switch off the the
thinking and go right to sleep it's
about for me they're really two blocks
two 90 minute blocks one early in the
day and one later in the day where I
commit to doing really focused work
twice a day and I have to fight tooth
and nail to create the space for those
and to make sure it happens and if it
and I fail a lot you know if something
gets in the way and I don't do that I um
I just try and get back on track as
quickly as possible I don't bring my
phone I put my phone on airplane mode
when I'm training and doing any kind of
physical work now because it's just too
distracting rule number eight deal with
your fears people form these
associations whether or not through
variants are through indirect experience
observing others I think public speaking
is one of the greatest fear of dying you
know it's funny I don't it's not funny
but figure of speech I never think about
dying and being afraid of dying I think
about all the scary things that could
happen while I'm living but there are
many people who are just intrinsically
afraid of dying
and so that's that's a big one
um for people that don't swim fear of
drowning for people that swim less so
for people that have some sort of
psychiatric disorder genuine psychiatric
disorder like obsessive compulsive
disorder which is not just pers
obsessive-compulsive personality but
obsessive-compulsive disorder fear of
the of being discovered and the shame
that they have around their obsessions
and compulsions these are true OCD is
very common do they all live in the same
place
all of these different fears that all
exist yes so I was rattling off and I
didn't answer your question
um to the the more important point so
forgive me
the short answer is they have a final
common pathway which is increased
autonomic arousal and that is funneled
through a couple what we call limbic
structures among others so there's
certainly involvement of the of the now
famous amygdala this which means almond
is this almond shaped structure on the
two sides of the brain there's also area
of the brain called the Streator
terminal analysis also involved in fear
and then the hypothalamus this small
collection of neurons just above the
roof of your mouth which is really to me
one of the more fascinating areas of the
brain Harbors neurons that create a
body-wide and braid and wide response to
something that the higher order areas of
the brain like the forebrain
see and perceive as dangerous as
threatening so the short answer is yes
it all funnels through hypothalamus
amygdal Austria terminalis and autonomic
nervous system that's the final common
pathway but in terms of the variety of
different things that can stimulate fear
and the ways that they can do that that
is highly contextual so the forebrain
this real estate in the brain right
behind behind the forehead is incredible
because it's sort of free real estate
for you to customize for your life
according to what happens to you early
on so for instance you might not be at
all afraid of heights
and you say well why is that so well
maybe when you were a kid you were one
of those Maniacs that like you know
doing within the states we called them
Cherry drops the kids that could you
know swing on their feet and then jump
off the the bar and then other kids are
timidly crawling to the top of the thing
don't even want to go up the ladder to
the slide there's a ton of variation and
that variation does not exist in the
kind of deeper circuitry the final
common path circuitry it exists in the
learning that we experienced early in
life one bad fall can do it I mean I Was
Bitten very badly by a German Shepherd
when I was a kid who had almost got my
eye but you know for whatever reason
I've always liked dogs anyway but there
are other things that I've experienced
that have left long-term negative
imprints so I it's highly contextual and
a lot of it has to do with what happens
immediately after the bad experience
this is why nowadays there's a lot of
legal use of the drug ketamine after
traumas you know this is all very dark
stuff unfortunately but if you you know
you just imagine the family member that
was just in a car crash and saw their
the driver their loved one impaled onto
the steering column I mean what could be
more horrible than that nowadays if they
come into the emergency room they will
often give them an injection of ketamine
which is the dissociative anesthetic to
get them to dissociate from this extreme
emotional state
so there are ways now to treat this and
ketamine is used clinically at later
periods too rule number nine balance
your emotions people that are always in
anticipation and desire and seeking
that's wonderful for pursuing goals
however it's terrible for enjoying life
and actually those people are actually
quite difficult to be around there's a
certain almost um sociopathic element to
people who are what they call
hyperdopaminergic people who are always
on the dopaminergic scale to the point
where they are always pursuing goals in
fact those people are known to be at
least in the psychological spectrum they
can be very manipulative you know
dopamine and the pursuit of something
doesn't necessarily have to be high
energy and intense from the outside when
you observe it from the outside in fact
there are people who will manipulate in
order to get what they want this has
been shown who have high levels of
dopamine release in their brain but
they've learned that a kind of passive
manipulation is the best way to maneuver
through a particular environment now I
don't want to focus too much on
sociopathy because those are kind of
extreme examples
but it just goes to show that people who
identify a goal and realize the series
of steps that they need to take in order
to achieve that goal can either do it
through ethical means or non-ethical
means they can do it through active
Pursuit being the kind of type a person
that's always declaring their goals and
going after it posting it on Instagram
telling everybody about it trying to
recruit others there's that phenotype
there's that kind of signature of
dopamine and then there are the people
that want to get what they want and
they're doing it by always serving other
people by always taking care of
everybody else's needs by always trying
to accomplish their goals but through a
mode that at least from the outside
seems more passive or more about
supporting others neither of these are
good or bad and that's because dopamine
is a molecule it doesn't care how you
reach your goals it only cares that you
reach your goals because the internal
sensation is one again of mild pleasure
a little bit of pain although more pain
over time if you're not reaching those
goals and it takes you away from the
here and now and remember 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is practice waking up early the question
is how to get enough sleep and how to
make sure you get into all these
different sleep States and this is
particularly important for you so-called
night owls there's a lot of controversy
out there as to whether or not different
so-called chronotypes exist that is
people who just naturally or genetically
want to be an early bird wake up early
and go to bed early so these people that
wake up at 4am and would be most
comfortable going to bed by seven or
eight pm or nine PM then there are
so-called night owls people that would
feel best or tend to feel best when they
go to sleep at 1am 2 A.M even 3 A.M and
like to wake up later 8 9 10 or even 11
A.M or noon and then of course most
people go to sleep somewhere between 10
pm and midnight and wake up somewhere
between 5 a.m and 7 A.M or I suppose
more typically 6 a.m and 8 A.M now
whether or not real chronotypes exist or
whether or not people simply select
schedules for sleep and wakefulness that
they like because of their social
schedules or the activities they enjoy
for instance some people like to really
go out they like to go out dancing or
hear music or spend time in venues that
are only open late at night and don't
even open until noon or after other
people like myself rarely go out at
night but I like to get up early I like
to exercise I like to see the sunrise
Etc so I don't know if I'm a morning
person or an evening person I just know
the things I enjoy tend to happen in the
early part of the day and the things
that I don't enjoy quite as much can
happen late at night
regardless of whether or not they're a
real genetic propensities to be a night
owl or an early bird or a sort of
typical person right there in the middle
it's very important that people have
some control over their sleep schedule
and even more important that people are
able to get sufficient amount of REM
sleep and slow wave sleep for many
reasons but including the reasons I
discussed in the previous study related
to metabolism
I'm very excited there for about a study
that came out in sleep medicine this was
a few years ago but somehow I missed
this one it was published in 2019 and
the title of this article is a resetting
the late timing of night owls has a
positive impact on mental health
physical health and performance this is
a study done in humans focusing
specifically on people that like to stay
up late and sleep in but who desire to
be able to get up and feel Alert in
order to go to work or study and they
want to go to sleep a bit earlier and so
there are a lot of questions embedded in
this study in particular whether or not
people can actually shift their schedule
by a few hours or more some people out
there contend that if you're a night owl
that's just going to be impossible or
very very challenging to do turns out
it's not impossible and it's not even
that challenging to do provided you do
the right things just a brief overview
of the study and then I'll give you the
key takeaways it was a randomized
controlled trial it involved a number of
different people both male and female
and what they did was they used
non-pharmacological practical
interventions in in a real world setting
here I'm paraphrasing they use targeted
light exposure
they used consistent sleep wake times
they used fixed meal times caffeine
intake and exercise this is one of the
reasons I love this study so much
because I've done episodes where I've
talked about temperature exercise
feeding and most importantly light
exposure as a way to control and shift
your sleep wake Cycles your so-called
circadian timing and entrainment
what did they find well they found quote
significant improvements in terms of
mood so far less depression and stress
subjectively measured as well as
improved cognitive performance that was
objectively measured so improve reaction
times improved physical grip strength
which is actually a measure not just of
strength per se but also of nervous
system function and a number of things
that people could do in order to
optimize their morning hours even though
they were night owls previously what do
they have people do well I'm just going
to list this off
and sort of uh rapid fire succession
then we'll provide a link to the study
if you want to learn more first of all
they told participants to try and wake
up two to three hours before their
typical wake-up time two to three hours
that seems brutal to me and probably
seems brutal to you if you're somebody
who typically wakes up at 10 A.M to try
and get up at eight or even 7 A.M
consistently
but they were also asked to maximize
outdoor light exposure during the
mornings for reasons that if you've
listened to this podcast before if
you've heard me talk about before you
know that I'm constantly talking about
I'll probably go into the grave shouting
please get as much light exposure from
sunlight early in the day as possible
because it sets in motion a huge number
of things that are beneficial for your
mental health and physical health
including dopamine production timing
melatonin production correctly reducing
cortisol Peaks late in the day etc etc
so they asked them to get a lot of
outdoor light exposure they didn't give
them a specific amount where they said
maximize outdoor light exposure during
the mornings the time before noon and
again they had them waking up two to
three hours before their habitual wake
up time they were also told and this is
very important if you're going to shift
your schedule earlier to try and keep
sleep wake times fixed
between their work days and their
weekends so not sleeping in on the
weekends or not having any sleep in days
regardless of how well they slept the
night before
how fixed within 15 to 30 minutes of
their
pre-designated time so if they were
waking up at seven o'clock one day they
set their alarm and they made sure they
got out of bed at seven o'clock every
day plus or minus 30 minutes but never
later than 7 30. never earlier than 6
30.
participants were also asked to try and
go to sleep two to three hours before
their habitual bedtime so again these
are people that want to stay up late
like 11 p.m perhaps but even as late as
1am or 2 A.M and now they are asked to
go to sleep two to three hours before
the habitual bedtime end to wake up two
to three hours earlier as I mentioned
earlier
they were also told and I love this
because it fits with many of the things
we've talked about on this podcast
before to try and limit light exposure
during the evenings dim the lights or
limit all together artificial lights
a lot of reasons for that I covered that
in the master sleep episode I covered
that in the optimize Health using light
episode you can find those at
hubermanlab.com they're asking them to
do that here and they ask participants
to keep a regular schedule for their
daily meals not eating on the hour for
consistently you know at 9 00 a.m noon 3
P.M exactly but within again about 15 to
30 minutes
they're always eating at the same times
that was also important and again that's
because we have these so-called food and
trained circadian clocks when you eat
tells your body when to be alert and
when you're not eating when to be asleep
and they were told to not drink any
caffeine after 3 P.M in the afternoon
another theme that we've talked about on
this podcast they were also told not to
take naps after 4 pm naps are an
interesting feature of the sleep wake
cycle to be very brief about this and to
pull from the episode that I did with
World sleep expert from University of
California Berkeley Matt Walker naps are
great for many people but don't nap if
it interferes with your nighttime sleep
and in this study they told them don't
nap after 4 pm and if you are a napper
don't nap for more than 90 minutes 10
minute naps are fine 20 minute naps are
fine zero minute naps are fine but don't
nap for more than 90 minutes and don't
nap after 4 pm and to exercise during
the morning now this one can be a bit
contra virtual because I know a lot of
the pts out there and a lot of the
online you know gym rats and people who
and Runners too for that matter will say
well in according to body temperature
and research it's best to exercise in
the afternoon look it's better to
exercise sometime as opposed to no time
but if you're focused on how to shift
your schedule earlier meaning get up
early and go to sleep earlier this study
had people exercise in the early part of
the day certainly before 2 pm and
ideally before noon so again this is a
really important study because it
combines a lot of different variables to
arrive at this very impressive shift
where people can get up two to three
hours earlier and then pretty
consistently and reflexively start going
to bed two to three hours earlier
feeling more alert during the day again
improvements in cognitive performance
mood and physical performance grip
strength Etc very few studies are able
to or willing to tackle so many
variables and combine them in one study
this paper I think does a marvelous job
of doing this and it's incorporating
things that individually each have some
support for them in animal studies and
previous human studies but as far as I
know this is one of the few studies that
really combines all these different
features in one place
eating times keeping those consistent
getting maximal sunlight exposure
earlier in the day getting up at a
consistent time going to sleep at a
consistent time and on and on it's a
really marvelous study for that reason
and I think for any of you that are
night owls and any of you that want to
reinforce your early waking and early to
bed times and I think for most all of
you who fall into that General middle
category of tend to go to sleep
somewhere between 10 pm and midnight
because that's most people and tend to
wake up sometime between 6 a.m and 8 am
well maybe you want to become more of an
early riser or maybe you're going to
travel or the seasons are changing and
you want to shift your time or you have
a new job Etc or something that's
actually very common in terms of
relationship struggle you want to match
your wake sleep times or maybe you want
to offset your wake sleep times from a
significant other
these sorts of approaches that I
described here and that are supported by
the data in this paper
are absolutely powerful and science
supported and I'm certain that if you
were to apply them that you would see
essentially the same effects that were
observed here
exploring Inhumans is the extent to
which people who can take on adaptive
decisions can take that adaptive
behaviors can take that stress response
and kind of move the Horizon in closer
and just focus on okay I'm in the high
stress regime this is really painful we
see this in we work on people
generalized anxiety who are trying to
overcome fear of heights and just
walking across a virtual height plank
can be terrifying for them but if they
can get one step in front of the other
despite high levels of anxiety they can
eventually overcome that and so we've
been looking at everything from how
breathing affects the anxiety response
to heart rate pupil size Etc I'd be
happy to talk about all that in as much
detail as you like but I think the
principle to take away is this that the
growth mindset is not about suppressing
anxiety so that you're able to move
cruise through things with ease that's
just one part of it it's really about
trying to understand that stress
response as key to your growth it's
absolutely key and I think people that
you know lift weights or run long
distance or are involved in competitive
Sports they fundamentally understand
this but even they kind of migrate away
from it over time where we recovery is
super important but you need the
stimulus right and the stimulus for
growth is that stress response and if
you think about it
evolutionarily let's say we were all
living in a little Clan here in the
audit offices and we didn't know
anything about the outside world we
would start to kind of eventually what
drove people to leave was they didn't
have enough of what they needed there's
this sort of the seeking right so if you
had enough everything you had enough
mates enough food enough water to be
fine but at some point there was some
deprivation and so we had to do a risk
benefit analysis and so it was really
about taking that anxiety and venturing
out into the unknown to find resources
some people died and some people
succeeded and they were rewarded and
with that reward came the idea that ah
there's something about looking out into
the environment that's useful that can
allow me to have more than I have in the
moment but you can't divorce yourself
from the anxiety of wondering whether or
not things are going to turn out okay
you can't divorce yourself from the
anxiety of of strain and effort there's
just simply no way and in fact you
weren't really designed to do it so to
kind of peel this around to a practical
answer because I often listeners and you
know and people want to know what do I
do with this is you know I think
the field of wellness and biohacking and
high performance is great but it lacks
definition so one thing I'd really like
to see more of in the in these
communities and in the scientific
Community for that matter is more
careful definition like what is
mindfulness like really what are we
really talking about what is stress and
what are stress mitigation processes
that are useful so one thing I think is
really useful is think about real-time
tools versus offline tools I believe
personally to everybody but they're not
their MMA fighter they're in a CrossFit
they're running Ultras or they're a
student in class that doesn't do
anything physical whatever it is has
four tools one tool to get you to
mitigate your stress response in real
time so let's say the stress response
hits you need to keep it you can't let
it go too high or too low you know you
don't want to suppress it but something
to do that you also probably want an
offline tool that allows you to raise
your ceiling on what stress feels like
you know I'm buds with whim and I've
known him for a long time and like you
know I think Wim Hof breathing is in
particular is a use useful tool for kind
of Shifting your perception of what
stressful is that's an offline tool it's
not you can do it in real time but it's
not you're not going to start Wim
hoffing in the middle of your like
rolling Jiu Jitsu because your breathing
has got to be devoted to other things so
you need offline tools and real-time
tools to cope with stress and I think
people need real-time tools and offline
tools to bring themselves into
heightened states of arousal right so
there are times when there's when you're
actually too low on the arousal plane
and the key is to get higher up there
where you can access even better levels
of performance and so I think the the
so-called autonomic nervous system it's
absolutely under our control it's a
total misnomer it's just that your heart
rate and your breathing are taken care
of on their own you don't need to flip
the on switch you wake up every morning
and you know if everything's going well
you're breathing and your heart rate is
going the way it should but you
absolutely have levers that you can
control and move in order to shift those
and I think that there's been a lot of
focus on like okay breathing is a great
tool or you know the ice bath is a great
tool but we really aren't thinking about
what they're best for and as a result of
that I don't think they'll ever evolve
past where they are unless we start
thinking okay like what's the utility of
breath holds no one can tell me like so
my lab is very interested in like in
trying to figure out what the utility of
breath holds is is it better at letting
you deal with adrenaline in your system
is it better at get carbon dioxide
tolerance you know
um for all the the incredible tools that
are out there there isn't a lot of good
information about systematic ways to
approach it and I don't want to peel
everything down to like a really
reductionist approach you know I'm
friends with Brian McKenzie and those
guys and you know Brian's about as
reductionist as you get in the
breathwork community and I love how
Quantum you know how he loves to
quantify everything that's one of the
things that initially brought us
together
um as friends and as uh as you know sort
of informal collaborators but I think
that this world of biohacking needs
definition you know it's it's kind of
ironic that in the weightlifting
Community they've really works things
down to a kind of a fine science whereas
in the endurance Community it's kind of
like
whoever you're listening to seems to be
the person who knows the most and I
don't claim to know everything or the
most at all I just would like to see
sharper definition on all this stuff
about stress stress mitigation ice baths
breathing and so on and of course there
could be other reasons that you're
experiencing brain fog maybe you know
for people that drink alcohol the night
before maybe they had alcohol for people
that maybe they ate a meal that was too
large before sleep maybe any number of
reasons right gotcha but
um getting adequate oxygenation of the
brain during sleep is key so learn to be
a nasal breather and for those of you
out there that say well I have a
deviated septum a lot of people think
they have deviated symptoms the problem
is they're not nasal breathing enough
the sinuses actually can learn to dilate
if you nasal breathe exercising while
nasal breathing it will kind of depend
on the sport like if you box oftentimes
there's the need to do a sh or you know
kind of like exhale on impact type thing
so I I don't think anyone should tamper
with their normal breathing patterns as
it relates to sport or singing or some
you know activity but what I'm talking
about is when you're just standing
around when you're walking down the
street any low level activity you're
working at your desk yeah you should be
nasal breathing and breathing regularly
that will reduce brain fog in many cases
the discovery of growth mindset is worth
thinking about so Carol's Discovery was
these kids that for whatever reason
you know like doing math problems even
though they knew they couldn't get the
answers right these were sure fail
problems so it's the same kind of people
that like doing puzzles and these kids
not surprisingly go on to do
phenomenally well in a number of
different areas of academic Pursuit you
know but what's interesting about growth
mindset is that it seems like there's
some attachment of the reward systems of
the brain to the action or the pursuit
of a goal not just achieving a goal and
when we step back and we look at what
that really entails at a neurochemical
level we have reward systems in the
brain they generally fall into two
categories they're the reward systems
that make you feel really good with kind
of the here and now and everything
that's it within the confines of your
skin and the things you already have you
know love of your dog love of your
spouse gratitude for all the things you
happen to have and and those are
generally governed by the release of
molecules like serotonin and oxytocin
okay but then there's another reward
system which is the one that drove a lot
of human evolution which is the dopamine
reward system now dopamine is a very
misunderstood molecule it's often talked
about only in the context of reward like
I'm going to work to this goal I'm going
to build my company I'm going to you
know get 10 years of press whatever it
is and you reach it and you get this
dopamine reward and indeed that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted enroute to rewards
while you pursue rewards now the ability
to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this covered you know pandemic
situation the but the amazing thing is
remember the brain only does five things
and we get to decide which of those
Sensations and perceptions have
relevance and which ones don't or which
ones are attached to a goal and which
ones aren't so growth mindset in its
purest form is the attachment of these
reward systems to the effort process to
the friction process and not just to
obtaining a reward and just as a kind of
final point to that there's a very um
well-known body of literature and
Neuroscience at least among
neuroscientists that talks about
something called reward prediction error
and it says if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too where you're in
real anticipation of something this is
gonna be great this is gonna be great
this is gonna be great and then you
reach that goal and it's kind of
underwhelming and that generally
triggers this this circuit that I
referred to earlier this kind of
disappointment or pro-depressive circuit
so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself I'm on the right track
this friction I'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good I'm gonna tell myself this is
for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we were talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the number of
things you can do or the energy to do
them so just as a last last point about
dopamine when we're in effort we're
always secreting adrenaline we're always
in Pursuit and it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team has depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine for any of us success in any
Endeavor is very closely related to how
much Focus we can bring to that endeavor
and the reward system you start to
realize is entirely internal no one's
coming along and cramming dopamine in
your ear or dripping it in your brain
it's all internal and this starts to
bring us into the kind of like
discussion around mindsets because so my
colleague Carol dweck who you know
popularized the same growth mindset it's
again a very misunderstood concept it's
the idea that we can change so that's
built into that but the discovery of
growth mindset was of these kids that
actually really enjoyed doing problem
sets that they knew they couldn't get
right but for them they would get this
like dopamine released from just
focusing on the problem they like doing
puzzles they couldn't get right it
sounds crazy but inevitably those kids
are very good at puzzles and very good
at math and these kinds of things so
growth mindset is I believe it was sort
of a neuro Neuroscience lens on growth
mindset would be that the agitation and
stress that you feel at the beginning of
something and when you're trying to lean
into it you can't focus is just a
recognized gate you have to pass that
through that gate to get to the folk
component and then if you can reward the
effort process you really start to feel
Joy on low levels of excitement in the
effort process that's that buffering of
adrenaline that's that feeling like yes
I've got a lot of adrenaline in my
system but I'm on the right path it
feels good to walk up this hill so to
speak and when you start to bring those
neural circuits together
you really start to create a whole set
of circuits that are designed to be
exported to any Behavior you want
so if it's writing a book great if it's
podcasting great if it's building a
business great if it's if it's you know
building a terrific relationship great
then the circuits that Mother Nature's
design are incredibly generic so that we
could adapt to whatever it is that we
need to do and I think the
misunderstanding around how these
circuits work has led to this idea that
there's some secret entry point maybe
marked flow on the door and there's a
trampoline up to that door and you just
open that door and you're going to be in
it right and nothing could be further
from the truth and anyone who's done
well in any career or athletic Pursuit
knows this but unfortunately there's a
kind of obsession with the idea that
it's all supposed to feel good and it
does feel good but there's a whole
staircase in which it feels kind of
lousy growth mindset which is the
academic Discovery and laboratory
discovery of my colleague Carol dweack
at Stanford is the Hallmark of growth
mindset is really two things one is I'm
not where I want to be now but I but I
will I'm capable of getting there
eventually the other is to attach a
sense of reward to the effort process
itself in fact don't reward the result
reward the effort that's right and if
you look at true High performers people
that are consistently good at what they
do they don't peek and go through the
postpartum depression and crash and come
back and their life is a cycle of ups
and downs but really people who are on
that upward trajectory consistently
those people attach dopamine to the
effort process and actually Carol's a
one of her original studies on the
discovery of growth mindset was these
kids that love doing math problems that
they knew they couldn't get right
so it's like the people love puzzles but
in this case they knew they couldn't get
it right but they loved doing it and it
incidentally or not so incidentally
these kids are fantastic at math when
there is a right answer because they
they feel some sense of reward from the
effort process yeah now the cool thing
about dopamine
is that it's very subjectively
controlled we can all learn to secrete
dopamine in our brain in response to
things that are in a purely subjective
way our interpretation our
interpretation and but it has to be
attached to reality so you know one
should never confuse what is real right
so no so if you're F if you're thinking
about the effort you're expending so
let's say somebody right now is
financially back on their heels and
they're setting up a new business for
instance and it's hard
if they can take a few moments or
minutes each day to reflect on the fact
that the effort process is allowing them
to climb out of their hole potentially
that it's giving them an opportunity
that it's
somehow
they are on the right path or if they're
not in movement along that path or at
least oriented on the right path they're
not lying in bed all day they're taking
a step if they can reward that process
internally two things happen
first of all the brain circuits that are
associated with building subjective
rewards and dopamine gets stronger so
you get better at that process and
second and most importantly dopamine has
an amazing ability to buffer adrenaline
and buffer epinephrine and what I mean
by that is there was a study that was
published in the journal cell excellent
Journal cell Press Journal a couple
years ago showing that with repeated
bouts of effort we use and we release
more and more epinephrine it's kind of
adrenaline but in the brain
with more effort every time every time
you put in effort so every time you make
for this let's keep it if I were to keep
it in the business context every time
you make to write that email every time
you let's say it's a person who's a
Craftsman and a crafts woman every time
you're working in the in the shop and
doing that every bit of effort
you're taking a little bit of money out
of this epinephrine account you're
spending epinephrine now at some point
those levels of epinephrine get high
enough that you you feel like quitting
it feels exhausting this was done in a
beautiful study actually where
um they control the visual environments
and they have the subjects EX exert
effort and they can control the visual
environment so sometimes the effort of
of taking steps and moving forward is
actually kind of pushing forward and
kind of swimming motion
um would give them the Sensation that
they were actually making progress and
other times it was an exercise in
futility where they would just keep the
the visual World stationary and they
would expend effort and they didn't
think they were going anywhere
epinephrine's climbing climbing climbing
and eventually they quit now dopamine is
able to push back on that epinephrine
and give you
anyone the the feeling that you could
continue and maybe even the feeling that
you want to continue and you've seen
this actually like football is a good
example two teams play say the Super
Bowl both teams are Max effort the
entire time yeah Max effort
the team that wins suddenly in a moment
has the energy to jump all over the
place party for days they can talk I
mean
right before that well that wasn't
glycogen or stored energy of any kind
except it was neural energy and what
happened was effort is this adrenaline
adrenaline adrenaline adrenaline
eventually people quit they just quit
the
dopamine is able to suppress that and so
then you're expending effort but you're
doing it from a place of feeling like
you have energy for it there was a paper
published that essentially was asking
why any human or animal quits at any
Behavior now certain behavior is like I
can't lift a car unless it's a very
small car I can't lift a car but if it's
we're talking about running or we're
talking about long bouts of work the
question is why do we quit like what is
that it turns out that every time we
exert effort a certain amount of
noradrenaline in the brain is released
and there's a sort of a counter in the
brain stem and at some point enough
noradrenaline is released and it shuts
down cognitive control deliberate
control over the motor circuitry and we
quit that's it but the thing that can
restore those levels or can sort of
reset those levels lower and give us
more gas more mileage is dopamine and it
makes perfect sense because our species
had to move against very challenging
things in in nature and in in terms of
in culture at every stage of our
Evolution including now 2020 is a good
example of this and when a good example
would be if you're really slogging it
out and things are miserable just think
like the worst family vacation
everything's a disaster or a very hard
physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you're almost immediately feel a sense
of relief you see this in the team that
wins the Super Bowl both teams slogged
it out you have to believe they were
both at Max effort the entire game look
at the team that wins they have extra
energy they're jumping all over the
place so it can't be physical energy it
can't be glycogen related it's not
Ketone related it's nothing in the body
in that sense it's dopamine's ability to
take that level of norepinephrine and
smack it back down and so we can learn
this right I mean I think this is where
there's real power like in your story
um or the story that I'm familiar with
from your book like the the ability to
push through those pain points is
something that we really can export to
other aspects of life because it's the
same neurochemicals that are involved so
when you get to a particular location or
maybe you're I recall
um you know a portion where you're just
you're feeling lousy you know you're
injured or you feel like you're hurt and
you can reframe it mentally
and think I'm actually still on the
ladder I'm still holding on to a rum I
know at least that much I'm still
breathing I know that much and the lift
that we get is not some psychological
pump up it's a neurochemical thing it's
dopamine suppressing norepinephrine and
saying you're on the right path you can
keep going it's a permission to keep
going and we grant that permission to
ourselves no one grants that permission
to us I think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that external rewards can
actually Propel us down long past of of
success and high performance they can't
no it's an internal sustainable fuel
source yeah yeah I have a friend from
the SEAL Teams and somebody asked us
recently we were given a talk um and
somebody said how can I make sure that I
continue to self-reward and I'm not
driven by these external rewards how can
I continue to have that drive and uh his
answer was very good he said give away
all the external rewards you know and
now not all everyone can afford to do
that it's just about you and you it's
just you and you and the more attached
there's a famous Stanford study done at
Bing Nursery School probably not far
where from where you were in the
dormitory there's a little Nursery
School in Escondido Village and they did
a study where they looked at kids that
like to um playing during their recess
it's all recess in nursery school but
they're drawing and they took the kids
that really like to draw
and they started giving them little gold
stars on their drawings and then they
like the gold stars for a kid that's an
extrinsic reward and then they stopped
doing that and the kids stopped drawing
they just they they associate the good
feeling of doing it with the external
rewards we have to be very cautious
about how much of our internal dopamine
we attach to external rewards if we want
to continue to grow and pursue and focus
and work hard if you just want to get to
some place and cash in
then fine but most people find
themselves in a pretty miserable place
because their dopamine was so attached
to external rewards they need more and
more well understanding that pain and
pleasure in this really dynamic balance
can also help us which in the following
way any pain that you feel the longer
day the less sleep the the kind of Agony
that things aren't working that power
outlet doesn't work or the Internet is
slow whatever it is
the amount of pleasure that you will
eventually experience
is directly relation related excuse me
to how much pain you experience so we
know this from actually what nowadays
would be considered quite barbaric and
unethical experiments where they would
give people electrical shocks and they
would measure their response and then
they say we're going to increase it
we're going to increase it eventually
they get to the point where a slight
shock that was previously very painful
actually evokes a sense of pleasure now
you couldn't do these experiments
anymore these are not the experiments I
do in my lab these are older experiments
but for instance I and this has been
discussed in scientific research papers
giving somebody uh like a 10-minute ice
bath for instance or even a three-minute
ice bath where a one minute ice bath is
quite painful but there was a study from
the University of Prague a European
Journal of physiology showed that after
a painful ice bath stimulus the amount
of dopamine release goes up for two and
a half hours to 250 percent above
Baseline and that's not because the ice
bath itself evokes dopamine release a
lot of people think oh cold water evokes
dopamine release No Pain evokes dopamine
release after the pain is over yesterday
I tweaked my back because I do this
stupid thing every few years the same
stupid thing and it's really painful and
then you just remember all the ways in
which you can't move around I was like
standing up this morning I'm like ah and
just walking is so painful as the pain
has started to dissipate you get a
little bit of a high right you get a
little bit of a Euphoria that's dopamine
because of the the degree of pain you
experienced previously predicts how much
pleasure sure so when you start a
company down in the dregs and you're
shoveling again
that's beautiful because that means that
the win that you achieve is going to be
as good or greater than the one you had
previously in your case with Quest and
so we go back to this example the person
that's not motivated that can't get off
the couch that doesn't want to do
anything well this is the problem we
remember the rad experiment they are
effectively the rat with no dopamine but
they can still achieve some sense of
pleasure by consuming excess calories by
consuming social media and look I'm not
judging I do this stuff too right
scrolling social media if you've ever
scrolled social media and you're like I
don't even know why I'm doing this it
doesn't really feel that good
and I can remember a time where you'd
see something it was just so cool or you
see something online I remember this
when TED Talks first came out I was like
this is amazing these are some at least
some of them are really smart people
sharing really cool insights and then
now that they're like a gazillion TED
Talks I remember spending a winter in my
office at when I was a junior Professor
cleaning my office finally and binging
TED talks in the background thinking
there's a good use of my time pretty
soon they all sucked to me I was like
this isn't good so what you need to do
is stop watching TED talks for a while
wait and then they become interesting
again and that's this pain pleasure
balance and so for people that aren't
feeling motivated the problem is they're
not motivated but they're getting just
enough or excess sustenance so they're
getting the little mild hits of opio it
becomes an opioid system and if you
think about the opioid drugs as opposed
to dopamine dopaminergic drugs
dopaminergic drugs make people rabid for
everything you know drugs of abuse like
cocaine and amphetamine make people
incredibly outward directed right they
hardly notice anything except what they
want more of more it's very it's bad
because those drugs trigger so much
dopamine release that they become the
reward it's very circular the only the
drug can give that much dope I mean
nothing they could pursue would give
them as much dopamine as the drug itself
so there's that and then there's the
kind of opioid like effects of
constantly indulging oneself with social
media or with video games or with uh
with food or with anything to the point
where it no longer evokes the motivation
in craving and this is really the New
Evolution of the understanding of
dopamine and Neuroscience which is that
dopamine itself is not the reward it's
the build up to the reward and the
reward has more of a kind of opioid
Bliss like property which itself is not
bad if it's endogenous released from
within but when we can just sit there
like they're like the rat with no
dopamine gorging ourselves with
Pleasures so to speak what you end up
with is somebody that feels really
unmotivated and those Pleasures no
longer work to tickle those feel-good
circuits and so there's no reason for
them to go out and pursue anything and
that's a pretty dark picture so the the
keys are to pursue rewards but
understand that the pursuit is actually
the reward if you want to have repeated
wins okay you the celebration has to be
less than the pursuit and that's hard
for some people to do they you know that
they it's got to be that your
celebration is slightly less
dopaminergic it can be very reflective
you can be in gratitude those are other
neurotransmitter systems but you don't
want to be on that high as you celebrate
the win
you want to be
trickling out your dopamine regularly
until you pursue things that beliefs are
attached to a set of rewards so what now
the dopamine system is exceedingly
powerful because dopamine is is a kind
of a dumb molecule it has no brain of
its own it's just a it's just a molecule
right it's just a chemical but when
dopamine is released in our brain
we first of all it tends to orient us
towards
goals in the outside environment it's
the it's the molecule not just a reward
but of motivation and when we release
dopamine we tend to see the world in
terms of external goals and so you can
imagine now if there's a process built
up inside us where our thoughts are
causing
dopamine release and dopamine is shaping
what we see as rewards what we perceive
as Rewards
that can be wonderful or terrible
depending on how that's harnessed so let
me understand this when we have
dopamine
triggered in our body it's attached to
because it's attached to some type of
belief we're going to continue to say
this feels good that's right so let me
keep thinking this way and viewing the
world this in this way because it's
going to keep making me feel good that's
right physically that's right wow even
if it's
there's some fact or Not facts
scientifically true or not we're harmful
to other people or harmful to yourself
if it makes you feel good you might
stick to that belief that's right so a
good example with dopamine is it with
anytime thinking about science and
Neuroscience in particular thinking at
the extremes can be kind of useful so
people who are very depressed who see no
possibility in the world if you talk to
a depressed person every response they
give is going to be but it's not going
to work out they are absolutely certain
that things are going to turn out bad
and there's a benefit for having that
belief and they're entrenched in it they
may actually be rewarding that somewhat
although typically depressed states have
very low dopamine at the opposite
extreme is Mania when people are in a
manic phase dopamine is very high we
know this and they see possibility
everywhere and there's certain things
are going to work out they they will
spend money they don't have they'll
create relationships they don't have
time and energy for they will overdo
everything and so somewhere in the
middle is this healthy range where where
can where we realize that how we view
the world is shaping the release of
these chemicals and I do believe this
happens when we have positive thoughts
we we get a lift if we if we can get a
lift from our positive thoughts
and then dopamine itself puts us in
relationship with the outside world such
that we view the outside world as having
more possibility that is going to put us
into forward momentum they're good there
are a lot of studies to support that
when dopamine is low we tend to see very
little possibility in the world and so a
positive thought triggers
forward movement potentially yes yeah so
positive thinking which a lot of people
will say well that's just positive
thinking that doesn't work some people
say well be positive think positive
others are saying that doesn't work
well with science I'm hearing you say it
gives you a little bit of a lift
absolutely the the key with positive
thinking it is that it has to be honest
it it can't be I've already won you know
I don't have an Olympic gold medal if I
could tell myself I'm gonna get one
tomorrow but I just don't have the
skills so that's not going to release
dopamine in my system how do you know
it's honest if you're in a depressed
state and you don't believe that you are
actually better off than where you're at
the key is to attach the so one thing to
understand is that dopamine release in
the brain is always subjective there's
no experience that that says uh that has
unique domain over dopamine release that
will only allow dopamine release so
if it's very subjective so if I say to
myself
I'm going to um get into the process of
doing something we have a new year
coming up so there'll be a lot of
resolutions soon the
it's not about if you attach the
dopamine release to the process of
effort or goal setting itself you'll
have more energy to be an effort and
then if you can attach dopamine release
to the belief that you're at least
heading in the right direction you'll
have more energy to keep going in the
right direction people make the mistake
of thinking that
the the positive thought process should
be attached to the finish line
it's not about thinking of already one
it's not about being delusional it's
about thinking that your training is
going to take you to the finish line and
so it's about moving that mental Horizon
and More close and more closely and then
triggering some sort of positive
internal representation of what you're
doing meaning thinking positive and
people this is usually where I get
stopped and people say wait but it
sounds so subjective tell me exactly how
to do it but here's the important
thought it's it's supposed to be
subjective this is for you it's true
yeah everyone needs to figure out what
allows them to continue to be in forward
momentum what allows them to constrain
the world of possibilities
and to go after goals and how often to
self-reward because but the key is the
self-word because if you start only
pursuing external rewards that's when
you are no longer in control of your
dopamine system because you're reliant
on actually something physically
happening in the physical world not
internal that's right and let's be
really really honest and burst the the
bubble that I feel like should have been
burst a long time ago which is yes
everybody including me it is possible
that you can do everything and still
fail no one wants to say that but the
way that you ensure against that is to
attach reward to the effort process
because the dopamine molecule creates a
sense of certainty and you're not trying
to create certainty about the final
outcome you're trying to create
certainty only about the next outcome
that's enroute to the final outcome the
next action you want to think about
Milestones yes and so people set out
with oh I'm gonna I'm gonna write the
Great American a novel or I'm going to
you know get the IPO and of course
that's an important you need to have a
sense of what the Finish Line would
actually look like but the more that one
can attach this subjective release of
dopamine process to the intermediate
steps through positive thinking and
action positive thinking in action the
the higher that probability goes toward
in science we say there's a probability
of zero to one the higher that
probability goes to one which is
certainty now
everyone knows in the back of their mind
that there is no absolute certainty when
I hear about you know athletes or
Fighters I was certain I was going to
win we all know that there's a point
zero zero zero zero zero doubt
in everybody right point zero zero
whatever that is now for some people
they might be able to push that number
way way out but certainty about outcome
is actually a form of delusion certainty
about Romania yeah that's right that's
right you see this in Mania and that's
why people start engaging their behavior
online this is going to happen that's
right the silver lining in this is that
when you create certainty about outcomes
you know you can control
you take over this neurobiological
system and you create almost certainty
that you will complete the process to
the end goal
perfectly previously I told you that
it's great to foreshadow failure that
that's a great way to get your system
into a state of activation I also told
you that you want to set goals that are
challenging but possible and again here
I'm paraphrasing from the work of Emily
balsetis I want to be very clear
there are a few other things that one
can do in order to bias the likelihood
that you will succeed in trying to
achieve your goals first of all limit
your options
trying to pursue too many goals at once
can definitely be counterproductive now
I realize that life is complicated we
all have multiple goals that we're
trying to pursue but if we have
particular goals that are important to
us we have to be careful to not get
distracted by other goals and many
people run into this problem so setting
one or two or maybe three major goals
for a given year is going to be more
than enough for most people and is
actually going to be challenging for
most people now of course we have daily
goals and monthly goals and yearly goals
but if we have big lofty goals we need
to be careful not to contaminate our
mental space and our visual space with
too many goals and why do I say visual
goals well
what various department stores and
supermarkets have discovered is that the
greater the number of things in our
visual attention the more that we can
draw our attention and our goals off a
line of pursuit what does that mean well
let's think about in the Practical
context this has actually been done big
department stores have figured out that
if they stock their shelves
chock-a-block with many many options of
food or clothing items or objects or
anything like that people simply buy
more stuff people are very prone to
orienting their attention to whatever's
in front of them you put a lot of stuff
in front of them their attention drifts
you put fewer things in front of them
their attention is more narrow
in a later episode we'll talk about
designing a workspace that's optimized
on the basis of this it doesn't mean
being in a room with nothing except just
your desk and a computer doesn't have to
be that sparse but visual sparseness
actually can help us Orient our focus
and our behavior when we have a lot of
things in our visual environment or a
lot of things in our cognitive
environment it's the same thing and so
if you're going to try and pursue a
fitness goal a relationship goal an
academic goal and a long-term Life
Financial goal all at once that's four
things and you're going to have to come
up with systems that allow you to
isolate those goals in a very rigid way
I'm never going to argue that we can
subjectively control all of our
experience because there's some things
that just genuinely suck right and when
they and it's important and it's
important to register those those not so
great events or terrible events because
they can drive us also you know we can
be driven from a place of anger
frustration and and you know revenge or
we can be driven from a place of you
know love gratitude and Etc I'm not here
to judge what which one is better or
worse but the nervous system doesn't
distinguish between them so if you're
the kind of person that needs to you
know kind of budge yourself into
something great if you're the kind of
person that wants to do things from more
of a warm fuzzy feeling that's fine too
what I will say is this the ability to
tap into this dopamine reward system
which is activated anytime you're in
pursuit of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know touch and comfort
and things like that with loved ones the
ability to tap into both is crucial now
you said something really important
which was well negative thoughts
negative thoughts what to do I don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts however when you
realize that thoughts can be
deliberately introduced you can start
replacing negative thoughts with new
types of thoughts so you can always add
something in and but when people start
to realize that thoughts are very much
like physical actions of reaching and
picking up a glass of water or taking a
jog around the ball block or typing an
email perfectly this is something I
sometimes do because I'm I you know I
struggle to do the perfect email not all
my emails are perfect but when I do one
I make sure that I I complete and I
think okay it's possible it's not
because the email being perfect is so
important it's because I want to remind
myself that my thoughts and my actions
are essentially the same the nervous
system can organize thoughts so for
somebody that's struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we we
have so many examples like that but in
trying to make it actionable it's really
about saying yep that's all true but I'm
going to introduce a thought which is I
made it through today I'm I made it
through today and that's actually worth
celebrating at a micro level so if you
can give yourself dopamine rewards in
small increments right you're not trying
to celebrate that you made it through
one day sometimes that's a huge feat but
most of the time you just want to dose
yourself with a little bit of that
internal release of dopamine you start
rewarding incremental steps and if
there's anything that your listeners
could take away from this whole thing
about dopamine and reward schedules and
being in movement it's reward
incremental steps in particular
incremental steps that are about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you as you get better at
things right the stairs get further and
further away from one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take the rungs on
the ladder further apart so to speak
that's a time when you really need to
implement not only the dopamine rewards
but also those serotonin and oxytocin
rewards Etc so to make it actionable I
would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
I can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way I can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh I'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently I don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push
[Music]
the video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
John Assaraf check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and it got me thinking about do
you even know what your A game is what
has to happen in order for you to be at
your best to play at your best is it a
routine is it a diet is it a way of
thinking